your experience on avengers has you've
just you've had a
litany of plot sports excuse me
me well no i'm the best
you're marginally better than tom
holland but that's it yeah
what i taught tom howard
tell us about the was it the premiere of
thor
uh okay come on you're wrong
it's all over now how far are you they
can't fire you no they tried
so if you don't know this story uh this
is what happened
are you cutting it's coming oh
so they asked me to do social media
backstage and at that time it was like
facebook live
had just hit the um the apps
and um and so i um
i i was back there doing my face time
facebook living
and um i thought i hit the off button
but i didn't realize it had two
different off buttons
and i went on when i ran to my seat they
started the movie i put my
my my phone in my pocket and i'm sitting
there watching it
and i'm like five minutes in and my
phone is blowing up
i'm just like and everyone
and their mother was texting me from all
over the world
to tell me that my phone was on and i
was live broadcasting
the but of movie
i'm a gentleman so i don't check my
phone
so finally they sent the lady down and
she
hey and i'm like what what and she's
like yeah phone
your phone is on i was like no it's not
it's it's in my pocket she's like
it's on it's on and i pulled it out and
i just like
oh
i get a call from kevin feige oh the big
boss the boss
he's like what are you doing man
i said kevin i it was an accident i
swear to god they told me to use the
facebook live i don't know how to use it
he's like you can't do this stuff
i was like no no you're right sir yeah
and the next day i showed up to do press
and i'm
i'm i'm hurting i i can't look anyone in
the eyes
and i walk over to him to say sorry and
he grabs me in a bear hug
and he's like that was genius
we got more press from that than
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hello oh my god
oh my god
he looks more like you than you just
that's where you're here
what's your name matt
now have you have you made yourself look
like matt smith
uh no i think i was born this way yeah
it's a tragedy is it yeah
where where do you live matt uh bristol
in bristol yes so close
to cardiff yes do you have a question
for matt smith yes i do
in the children need clip that was shown
um david tennant wears the fez
and i was wondering if any more hats
were involved in the episode and did you
get the fez on john hurt
[Applause]
sorry matt i'm sorry buddy
if you stood face to face it would look
like a
i mean vase does look very like you
thank you very much have you seen him
before
no no who's up next who's up next
oh
[Applause]
okay one more one more hi oh hello
what's your name sir stefan stefan and
where are you from los angeles
and have you flown in for this we yeah i
did actually i've been
um flying around the world not to outdo
the girl earlier but
i've been working on a doctor who tattoo
and um
and i've been having all the doctors to
actually sign my arm and have it
tattooed over the ideas to get them all
oh chris um actually since we're talking
about it wait wait hang on
a moment yeah
yeah and i was pissed and i said careful
cause i was drunk and
you actually did it is that where
where's matt i did yeah matt's right
here and then uh sylvester mccoy
is here and peter davidson and i'm
actually missing david
oh we actually figured in a spot
specifically for you to sign
okay what's your name again stefan okay
stephan quickly someone will show you
how to get into the studio run in quick
quick quick
quickly leave your jacket baby jacket so
uh
tell him about leona maybe he could sign
it somewhere else oh yes
[Applause]
[Music]
an incredible outfit where did you get
all this stuff um this was actually from
debit house i
was lucky enough to get one of these
they're amazing so why did you go in
here
yeah that was that was actually made
specifically for you mr jimmy carr wants
to ask him a question
what do you think it's going to be like
to touch a girl
[Applause]
i'm married to the dalek you're married
to the dalek of course you are
[Applause]
i'm kind of nervous yeah
beautifully done thank you david
uh well done
[Applause]
have you guys seen the fan art no have
you seriously i saw
[Music]
it's i know than that real photo you
showed me in the way
that's just scary but no and what if
what if they're
at the craft services during filming one
of them gets hungry
why you could share a cherry
you've never made any cupcakes
but what are you what are you wearing
james in there am i wearing dungarees
you did the baking and i'm feeding you
oh that's great yeah that's lovely yeah
you've worked hard all afternoon james
you deserve a treat so i'm taking your
cherry
meanwhile meanwhile after filming you're
just relaxing don't do this
you know what i'm saying first of all
what i'm saying is i know it's tough
being number nine
[Laughter]
but here you are baking it's rather
beautiful
now for some reason somebody's screaming
wait a minute wait a minute stop
everything for a minute
whoever's creating this artwork i
applaud your artistry by the way it's
beautiful work but um if anybody's given
[Laughter]
my face no no but the obviously
the weird thing is i don't know what but
james looks incredibly like sue lawley
here
i also think i look a bit like that's
that's like that's right
it looks no it looks like what you're
saying is if anybody's doing the giving
it's me
you know i think it really looks like it
looks like a couple we've been together
for 25 years and they're like you know
we've
had sex in a long time and come on let's
try
we don't even take our pants off
[Laughter]
so but then from there this is even
sweeter what they do is they've got
these
various scenarios uh they dream up for
you
and what you do is if you go to the fan
fiction websites
right and this when i say fanfiction
websites this is nuts
some of these stories are 250
000 words long that's like two
books yeah amazing
okay so what they do is they summarize
them so
here's the little one so here's harvey
weinstein optioned them for him
really should so there's one like
michael fassbender is a powerful man
with powerful enemies
he asked the agency for the best they
had they sent him
[Applause]
i'm trying to stay away from this as far
as i'm happy to get
so this involved these are the little
scenarios for you do you go with the
first one there now
after finding out james is pregnant with
twins
ibf can do incredible things james and
michael start to learn
how to balance upcoming parenthood and
their careers with help
from friends and family see it's lovely
okay this one and they like to say they
are sweet they're creepy but sweet
james and michael decide to knit scarves
for each other
wait wait wait james is very good at it
[Applause]
but michael ends up with something
that is definitely not a scar
[Applause]
michael likes certain kinks in bed role
play
and costumes and scenes i thought it was
saying sconzy
oh and that cream james has never really
minded before but this time this night
he's tired
he feels a bit ridiculous in the outfit
and he wants michael
to want him as himself for once
[Applause]
it's not just the legacy players that
return uh
some of the iconic uh proppage is back
and john you are you presumably do you
you
trained with your saber the lightsaber
yeah yeah yeah
stuff yeah now i've got a very posh
lightsaber here would you show us a few
like
is it like is it just the same as
learning fencing or is it something
different to it
it's slightly different is it slightly
different but i won't spoil anything
right what have i got i've got luke's
here somewhere is this this is luke's
yeah yeah oh my gosh oh no it's really
this is really spendy and posh
where'd you sell that from a shop i
don't know
carrie nicked it and gave it to me
[Laughter]
is this what they look like on set
pretty much yeah oh really
so this bit does exist yes and with the
lights and everything oh it does yeah
yeah but do you know how to turn that on
because i don't
why is this a complicated one
[Applause]
oh
you nearly took out a pop princess
it's so long it's not the one on set
it's longer oh is it yes it is
very good thank you very much
you